from hotel which sits just down the
street from the White House may soon be
on the markets the property lease from
the federal government by the
president's family has been a go-to
destination for lobbyists foreign
governments and federal officials but as
we judging reports it's also raised
questions over whether President Trump
is profiting from his presidency since
its opening shortly before the 2016
election the hotel on Pennsylvania
Avenue has brought money and controversy
to the Trump family in a statement the
president's son Eric Trump said it might
be sold because people are objecting to
US making so much money you beat out a
number of competitors to get this it's
amazing we beat out pretty much everyone
in the luxury hotel space CBS News got
an exclusive look at the hotel in 2014
after the Trump Organization leased the
old post office building from the
federal government and now brings in
more than 40 million dollars in revenue
each year and could be sold for a half
billion president Trump himself has
dined and visited the hotel 23 times
other executive branch officials have
made nearly 400 trips there mr. Trump's
personal lawyer Rudy Giuliani was
photographed at the hotel with two
associates since arrested in the Ukraine
controversy and the President of the
Philippines picked it to host an event
just one of several foreign officials to
use the property few people in Estonia
monument laws just this week President
Trump dismissed the constitutional ban
on presidents profiting from the US or
foreign governments the Trump Hotel is
an unnecessary nuisance in the view of a
lot of Republicans they would just as
soon he get rid of it Republicans also
objected to president Trump picking his
Doral Resort in Florida to host the g7
summit the Trump team could be
offloading controversies as the
impeachment inquiry and the twenty20
race heat up for CBS this morning
Saturday we judge Aang at the White
House